parle avec jean paul giacometti vice
président chez claret gestionnaire de
portefeuille bonsoir bonsoir plaisir de
vous revoir ça faisait un petit moment
même si vous alors vous venez avec des
bonnes nouvelles est ce que ça va durer
ce marché haussier mais est-ce que ça va
durer si vous me demandez ça va durer un
mois j'en ai aucune idée s'est fait peur
mais aussi si vous regardez le marché
boursier sur le long terme ne vous
prenez un graphique vous allez voir que
la tendance allait toujours dans le même
sens ce qui s'est passé dans la dernière
séquence parce que si on est en train de
mesures an de récession
en fait ça aucun impact sur ce qui va
arriver l'an prochain c'est à dire on
mesure en deux récessions vous avez
parlé par exemple des années 50 c'est
pas le même style d'environnement du
tout qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs cette séquence depuis la
dernière récession de 2008
elle est très longue mais la croissance
économique est très faible
c'est la plus faible en fait de toute
l'histoire sur une une si longue
séquence du marché ans de récession
ensuite vous avez la récession dans les
années 50 était de plus courte durée
c'est un industrie plus manufacturière
aujourd'hui on est une industrie de
services
oui donc c'est difficile c'est sûr donc
plus vous étirer le temps de récession
plus aller faire un record important oui
exactement
mais en même temps est-ce qu'on doit
quand même être impressionné par la
croissance et la durée de la montée
boursière depuis 2002 cet intéressant
c'est bien est-ce qu'on doit être
impressionné dans les années 50 si vous
prenez année par année il ya une année
où je pensais monter de 46%
c'est certain que si vous êtes investi
cette année là ça vaut la peine
donc oui mais ça fait partie du jeu à
long terme
donc quand on investit c'est ça qu'il
faut regarder fondamentalement qu'est ce
qui explique selon vous la montée
boursière qu'on connaît il ya plusieurs
raisons
une des raisons principales c'est les
taux d'intérêt qui baissent de 4 à 1
sa part est pour beaucoup 3% mais en
pourcentage de bain c'est beaucoup c'est
pas comme baissé de 7 à 4 ou de dire ça
l'impact est beaucoup plus grand les
banques centrales aussi un effet
important sur
sur le marché oui c'est jette beaucoup
de duels sur le feu donc ils encouragent
en mettant les taux à zéro finalement
vous appelez ça de l'huile sur le feu
mais c'est parce qu'il reporte si on
regarde en europe par exemple que des
taux d'intérêt négatifs l'on se parle
même pas de on parle de vous prêter 100
euros aux allemands ils vous redonne 100
heures ou 30 ans plus tard ça pour moi
c'est anormal c'est un signe de malaise
ainsi trop loin c'est pas normal que
l'économie soit construite cette façon
donc ça c'est pour encourager les
consommations encourager pic bref ça
créé des mouvements de fonds qui vont
dans le marché boursier entre donc c'est
malsain c'est malsain à long terme moi
je pense pas que ça va durer très
longtemps parce que on s'appuie sur des
bases médecine en ce moment pour
plusieurs raisons que ces mêmes sites en
europe par exemple c'est que ça favorise
les riches ça défavorise les pauvres
ceux qui ont de l'argent peuvent
emprunter à zéro ce qui peut on pas
d'argent peuvent pas emprunter
bref une longue histoire mais en bout de
ligne quand on veut investir c'est ce
qu'on paye qui compte c'est pas la
séquence qu'on vient de vivre c'est pas
si ça monte beaucoup et l'on est à 20
fois les profits oui c'est patronymique
malhomme 20 fois les profits les
entreprises du s&p 500 annonce des
résultats qui représente 20 fois leur
pour moins exact c'est donc autrement
dit quand on regarde d'historiquement
l'évaluation de ce cet indicateur là on
peut aller plus loin encore plus loin la
moyenne historique ce sens mais c'est
tout une fonction des taux d'intérêt a
su que je l'avais répété dans le parti
si les taux d'intérêt restent bas
c'est très bon pour marchés boursiers
donc c'est à vous de voir vous tout le
monde et qu'est ce que les taux
d'intérêt vont faire si vous croyez
qu'ils restent dans les 1 2 3 pour sa
vingt et une fois les profits c'est pas
cher ouais
maintenant qu'est ce qui peut faire
dérailler le marché présentement de quoi
qu'est ce qu'il faut surveiller de quoi
faut-il s'inquiéter mais on oublie que
le marché boursier s'est pas une ligne
droite à la hausse
il ya beaucoup de confiance à la barre
on le voit de tout voyons depuis dix ans
qu'il ya des moments de baisse qui en
avait eu à la fin de 2018 est exact
qu'on a oublié qu'ils étaient les jours
ça et puis on ne rebondit ensuite mipim
20% normalement dans les six mois qui
suivent
une récession qu'on n'a pas eue et ça
c'est pas parce qu'ils n'ont donc c'est
que le marché boursier n'est pas un prix
dit le dicton quatre indicateurs avancés
pour les récessions et les récessions
sont encore moins un indicateur avancé
pour le marché boursier soit aucun n'a
pas une récession l'an prochain ça veut
pas dire que le marché boursier ne
montrent pas donc ces périodes là
arrivent
est ce qu'il va en avoir un mois
prochain c'est possible mais qu'est-ce
qui peut dérailler
je ne sais pas donc qu'est ce que vous
diriez qu'une bulle quelque part la
bulle d'après moi un et pas dans le
marché boursier
allez dans le marché obligataire des
mouvements de 1% à 2% taux d'intérêt ça
peut faire dérailler le marché
obligataire drastiquement la performance
des marchés obligataires des fonds
obligataires l'an passé 7 2 7 8 9 %
mais comment faites vous pour 7 8 9 % si
vous avez juste 1% de coupons c'est
parce que les taux bas sans arrêt alors
comment les gens doivent se comporter le
petit investisseur qui nous écoutent ce
soir il se comporte comme un sas a
suffit d'une bonne question c'est qu'il
faut pas oublier que le marché boursier
s'est pas pour le mois prochain
c'est que c'est pour le plus long terme
plus long terme ces deux trois quatre
ans donc c'est pas parce qu'aujourd'hui
on vient de faire un nouveau record de
la façon qu'on mesure qu'il faut être
prudent ou pas prudent deuxième jaune
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on paye qu'est ce
qu'on a pour ce qu'on paie c'est ce qui
est important
vingt fois les profits dans l'ensemble
c'est pas cher maintenant si vous voulez
acheter plus spécifiquement regardez
qu'est ce que vous achetez en ce moment
là de la mode chez les compagnies qui
ont beaucoup de croissance pas de revenu
moins de profits pardon ça pour moi
c'est plus dangereux
oui effectivement hockey à suivre jean
paul giacometti merci merci merci
beaucoup